hope you're taking notes pixar because
this is how you do it
secret of kells this movie came out of
nowhere and got nominated for an oscar
and like most people was like secret or
what huh i mean i follow animation i
follow what's going on out there i've
never heard of this thing and then i
finally got to see it oh my god this
thing is amazing and gorgeous it's
fantastic stylized artwork it's a movie
that really embraces the time and place
in the way that i wish pixar's brave had
done you may remember that my major
complaint with pixar's brave is that it
had this fantastic character in this
magnificent setting and then told a
story that could have been said anywhere
secret of kells embraces the the
mysticism and the feeling of its time
period in its setting in a way that i
wished brave had done but it's so
fantastically done here and the stylized
animation really works very well and you
get sucked into it so quickly and it's
telling you this story of of this abby
and of this young boy and the things
that he's discovering but also the the
fears of reality and what and what's
going on out in the world and it
astounded me afterwards to find out how
much of it was based on truth there's a
lot of real folklore and real fact
behind this movie and it's good for most
ages it's got a really great sense of
wonder and magic to it which is always
something that i love when i can find it
i would caution parents about really
young ones because there is a little bit
of darkness and a little bit of death
towards the end of it so you you want to
be a little bit cautious in terms of
somebody really young who might
otherwise get taken in by by the art
style and the fun of it all if you like
animation if you like celtic medieval
settings if you just like beautifully
told stories check this thing out it is
absolutely worth your time and anyone
who's seen brave whether you were
disappointed by it or whether you loved
it you checked this thing out i can
almost guarantee you that you're gonna
love it anybody else got any animation
sort of set in that sort of celtic
scottish medieval ireland scotland sort
of setting that you really love you want
to throw in the ring and have them duke
it out with this and brave leave
something down in the comments let's
talk about it and i'll be back as soon
as i get my next fix